una agencia de boletos vende
aproximadamente 42 tickets para un
evento y los boletos cuestan 29 pesos
cada uno entonces si quisiéramos
aproximar o estimar el total de dinero
que generan con la venta de dichos
boletos qué pasaría entonces si
quisiéramos tener el número exacto
podríamos decir que sería 42 que fue
unos tickets que se vendieron por 29 y
trabajar con dicha multiplicación
presencialmente deberemos estar listos
para poder realizar en nuestras cabezas
dicha multiplicación aunque hay que
redondear ahorita los números y luego
multiplicarlos para sacar una estimación
bien y si queremos redondear sólo
tenemos dos lugares aquí vamos a querer
redondear a la decena más cercana pues
el número de espacios que tenemos son 2
por lo que si redondeamos 42 a la decena
más cercana hemos hecho esto varias
veces entonces el 2 como es menor que 5
entonces vamos a bajarlo al menor entero
entonces sería la decena más cercana 40
para el 29 el 9 es el master es mayor
que 5 por así decirlo entonces vamos a
redondear lo a la decena más grande que
sería 30 y ahora si realizamos dicha
operación y será más sencillo puesto que
podríamos multiplicar 4 por 3 que es 12
y después poner simplemente dos ceros
que se da desde el cero del primer
elemento del color magenta y el cero de
nuestro segundo elemento entonces cuatro
por tres como estoy encerrando por aquí
es 12 y vamos a colocar ahora si nuestro
primer cero que es el magenta y nuestro
cero color azul de el 30 y entonces esta
operación es de 1200 que es nuestro
estimado de dicho dinero